and
ultimately also trying to discover like
you're saying the self-supervised
formulation of the problem so the
unsupervised formulation of the problem
like uh you know in driving there's this
really interesting
thing which is you look at a scene
that's before you and you have data
about what a successful human driver did
in that scene you know one second later
it's a little piece of data
that you can use just like with gpt3 as
training
currently if you know tesla says they're
using that it's an
open question to me how much how far can
you can you sell all of the driving
with just that self-supervised piece of
data
and like i i think that's what comedy is
doing
that's what common ai is doing but the
question is how
how much data so what common ai doesn't
have
is as good of a data engine for example
as tesla does that's where the
like the organization of the data i mean
as far as i know i haven't talked to
george
but they do have the data the question
is how much data is needed
because we say infinite very loosely
here uh it's it's
and then the other question which you
said i don't know if you think it's
still an open question
is are we in the right order of
magnitude for the compute
necessary um that is is this is it like
what elon said this
chip that's in there now is enough to do
full self-driving or do we need another
order of magnitude
i think nobody actually knows the answer
to that question i like the confidence
that elon has but
yeah we'll see there's another funny
thing is you don't learn
to drive with infinite amounts of data
you learn to drive with an intellectual
framework that understands physics and
color and horizontal surfaces and laws
and roads and
you know all your your uh experience
from manipulating your environment
like look there's so many factors go
into that so then when you learn to
drive
like driving is a subset of this
conceptual framework that you have
right and so with self-driving cars
right now we're we're teaching them to
drive with driving data
you never teach a human to do that you
teach a human all kinds of interesting
things
like language like don't do that you
know watch out you know there's all
kinds of stuff going on
you